[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend ihnen allen wir bringen sie
in den kommenden 25 minuten auf dem
neuesten nachrichten stand die vom sport
hat kristin otto guten amt
aktien des krieges in der ukraine die
versorgungslage spitzt sich immer weiter
zu
seit tagen stehen mario pohl und wohl
nur wache unter heftigem beschuss heute
sollte eine waffenruhe die evakuierung
der bewohner ermöglichen doch sie hielt
nicht lange
auch für berichterstatter wird es immer
gefährlicher ein britisches fernsehteam
wurde beschossen
russlands präsident putin kritisiert die
westlichen sanktionen scharf sie glichen
einer kriegserklärung
es war ein kleiner hoffnungsschimmer bei
der verhandlungsrunde am donnerstag in
belarus hatten sich die russische und
die ukrainische seite auf eine
feuerpause geeinigt sie sollte heute
erstmals für fünf stunden einen
humanitären korridor ermöglichen um
zivilisten sicher aus mario pohl und
wohl nur wasser zu bringen doch daraus
wurde nichts stattdessen weitere heftige
gefechte auch in der umgebung von kiew
alexandra vacano und christian volk
berichten
nichts wie weg wer kann rettet sich aus
dem umkämpften gebiet wie die frauen
männer und kinder hier aus ihre pin ihre
kleinstadt heute unter beschuss sie
liegt auf dem weg richtung kiew ein weg
auf dem die russische armee versuchen
könnte richtung hauptstadt vorzurücken
dort hinten verläuft die frontlinie
erklärt uns lena waldeck als wir heute
nachmittag mit ihr telefonieren sie
wohnt am nördlichen stadtrand von kiew
und will bleiben mit mann und hund noch
wir verteidigen unsere unabhängigkeit
denn ich habe angst davor ein teil
russlands zu werden ich fürchte mich vor
dieser aussicht wenn es passiert dann
verlassen wir auf jeden fall das land
denn unter einem russischen regime kann
ich nicht leben
hier hofften sie heute auf eine
feuerpause in der eingekesselten
hafenstadt mario pohl rund 200.000
menschen sollten verlassen und 15.000
voldo wacher im osten der ukraine
doch die vereinbarte feuerpause ist
brüchig gegenseitige schuldzuweisungen
so sagt der stellvertretende
bürgermeister von mario pohl
was die russische seite sagt stimmt
nicht sie fahren damit fort mario pohl
zu zerstören deshalb haben wir
beschlossen unsere bürger zurück zu
bringen weil es nicht sicher ist auf der
straße zu sein
russland dagegen sagt die behörden von
mario pohl hindern die bürger daran die
stadt durch den humanitären korridor zu
verlassen den das russische militär
geschaffen hat
insgesamt habe ich das gefühl dass das
ukrainische regime nichts dagegen hat
die zivilbevölkerung darunter auch
ausländische studierende als geiseln bei
sich zu behalten
überprüfen lassen sich die aussagen
beider seiten nicht
der russische präsident trifft derweil
flugbegleiterinnen der russischen linie
aeroflot und übt in seiner rede die vom
staatlichen fernsehen übertragen wird
kritik an den westlichen sanktionen
diese glichen einer kriegserklärung sagt
er
in der ukraine ist die lage auch für
journalisten lebensgefährlich diese fünf
britischen reporter haben glück sie
können fliehen
und finden schutz in einer fabrik
takt 10 des krieges und es fehlen
elementare dinge wie essen und getränke
in mario pohl plündern menschen ein
einkaufszentrum die lage hat sich
dramatisch zugespitzt so das
welternährungsprogramm der vereinten
nationen und sie sie sind gerade alt
genug um ihr land zu verteidigen
seine mutter habe gesagt geh nicht
erzählt er aber er will kämpfen
katrin eigendorf ist für uns in der
mitte des landes wie ist die aktuelle
situation bei ihnen katrin
ja hin manager wird nicht aktiv gekämpft
aber die stadt merkt man befindet sich
auch in einem krieg wie man vielleicht
hier hinter mir sieht die ganze
fußgängerzone der innenstadt hier sind
überall bilder aufgehängt von ukraine an
den letzten acht jahren die ihre dieses
krieges ihr leben verloren haben man
hört hier permanent wie die
nationalhymne gespielt wird die meisten
geschäfte haben geschlossen nur noch
wenige restaurants funktionieren in
einer stunde ist hier sperrstunde dann
müssen wir ja auch abbauen und in unser
hotel zurückgehen es hat immer wieder
auch
luftalarm gegeben das heißt man rechnet
auch jeder mit möglicherweise irgendwann
aus der luft angegriffen zu werden was
auffällt die meisten männer haben die
stadt verlassen die frauen die hier
geblieben sind sind fast nur damit
beschäftigt flüchtlinge zu versorgen
nachschub für die soldaten an der front
zusammenzustellen und es herrscht ein
unglaubliches misstrauen hier in der
stadt ich werde immer wieder
angesprochen als ausländerinnen gefragt
wer bist du was machst du zeig deinen
ausweis also man hat hier sehr sehr
große angst davor dass auch hier in der
stadt russische saboteure einsickern das
ist ja überall in der ukraine passiert
und hier möglicherweise auch angriffe
auf menschen begehen oder markierungen
machen die der russischen luftwaffe den
weg weisen um hier angriffe zu verüben
die winterruhe live aus managt
dankeschön katrin eigendorf
weit über eine million menschen sind
schon vor dem krieg aus der ukraine
geflohen ähnlich viele dürften im land
selbst auf der flucht sein schätzt die
uno
viele menschen suchen schutz in der west
ukraine die bisher von den kämpfen noch
weitgehend verschont geblieben ist in
der großstadt lemberg hat armin coerper
mit geflüchteten gesprochen
sie haben es geschafft in einen keller
irgendwo in lemberg anja und lisa sind
heute aus aktiv mit dem zug gekommen und
zeigen uns bilder von ihrem zuhause das
keines mehr ist tagelang haben sie dort
in einem bunker ausgeharrt wir hatten
mal ein glückliches leben die haben es
zerstört und eine hölle daraus gemacht
auf dem weg zum bahnhof sind wir durch
die ruinen unserer heimat gelaufen das
hat mir das herz gebrochen
ich kann das nicht glauben
sie wollen nach deutschland dort wartet
anjas patentante doch ihrer flucht durch
ihr land im krieg ist noch lange nicht
vorbei diese menschen haben ihr altes
leben zurück gelassen weil es nicht mehr
existiert sie sind jetzt hier und auf
der suche nach einem neuen leben
irgendwo in sicherheit im zimmer nebenan
nikita und mascha ihr zuhause in kiew
ist ein trümmerfeld sie zeigen uns ein
video aus ihrem stadtviertel
[Musik]
wo sollen wir denn das geld hernehmen um
das jemals wieder aufzubauen ich habe
keine ahnung dafür hasse ich putin
laut gesetz müssten die kita kämpfen und
sich dieser gewalt und zerstörung
entgegenstellen doch er weiß dass er das
kaum überleben würde
ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen ich
kann doch gar nicht kämpfen ich bin
nicht so stark ich war nie beim militär
aber womöglich habe ich keine wahl er
könnte zwangs eingezogen werden die
angst von die kita und mascha ist die
von vielen menschen am tag 10 des
krieges in der ukraine
fangen wir noch mal nach bei armin
coerper auch die versorgungslage wird
laut blue immer schwieriger soeben sind
die ersten jobs eines un hilfskonvois
bei lemberg angekommen kommt die hilfe
überhaupt bis in die umkämpften gebiete
und was wird da am nötigsten gebraucht
wird wasser außerdem medikamente
medizinisches versorgungs und
verbandsmaterial genau das hat dieser
unicef konvoi heute an bord 60 tonnen
davon
das wird jetzt hier vor lemberg
umgepackt auf kleinere transporter
verteilt und dann in unterschiedliche
krankenhäuser in verschiedenen teilen
dieses riesigen landes gebracht diese
reise ist extrem gefährlich die straßen
sind sowieso schlechte saarland
weitestgehend unter beschuss und man
rechnet damit sagt man mir hier dass die
drei bis vier tage brauchen um an orten
wir aktiv und mario pohl anzukommen und
was man mir aus auch hier sagt ist an
die humanitären zusagen russlands von
korridoren oder sicherem geleit für
hilfsgüter daran glaubt hier wirklich
niemand
dankeschön armen körper in lemberg
bei dem zdf haben die berichterstattung
aus ihren studios in moskau erst einmal
ausgesetzt sie prüfen die folgen eines
gestern in russland verabschiedeten
mediengesetzes für missliebige
berichterstattung über die russische
armee drohen demnach harte strafen die
beiden öffentlich rechtlichen folgen
damit sendern wie bbc oder cnn die ihre
arbeit in russland schon gestern
teilweise oder ganz eingestellt hatten
ard und zdf werden von ihren anderen
standorten weiterhin umfassend über das
geschehen in russland und der ukraine
informieren
blicken wir nach polen wichtiges nato
mitglied im osten und das land das
aktuell die meisten flüchtenden aus der
ukraine aufnimmt das wird international
hoch anerkannt auch von anthony blinken
dem us aussenminister der heute vor ort
ist hannah hebestreit berichtet
ausflug hafenchef im südosten polens die
logistische drehscheibe für die
internationale ukraine hilfe
vollbeladene flugzeuge bringen was immer
im grenzgebiet gebraucht wird und sei es
diplomatische unterstützung für polen
dass die hauptlast trägt bei der
versorgung von flüchtenden
us-außenminister blinken würdigt einen
wichtigen verbündeten bis morgen in
diesem moment der krise vier millionen
ukraine die auch die sicherheit europas
bedroht 60 polen entschlossen und
hilfsbereit für die gute zusammenarbeit
die uns schon lange mit polen verbindet
sind wir dankbar über 800.000 menschen
aus der ukraine haben seit beginn der
kämpfe schon den polen schutz gesucht wo
man sich gut organisiert und offen zeigt
für alle die noch kommen
wir werden weiterhin menschen aufnehmen
die unsere hilfe brauchen ganz gleich
welcher nationalität und unabhängig von
ihrer religion
[Musik]
vor seiner weiterreise in andere staaten
der region besuchte blinken eine große
unterkunft für geflüchtete sich
erscheint es werden noch viel mehr
frauen und kinder aus der ukraine in
polen schutz suchen
die solidarität ist gewaltig deutschland
bereitet sich darauf vor jetzt auch
verletzte und kranke aus dem
kriegsgebiet aufzunehmen damit alle
geflüchteten hier gut versorgt und
untergebracht werden versuchen kommunen
nachbarschaften und vereine möglichst
eng zusammenzuarbeiten
stündlich kommen mehr aus mehr menschen
aus der ukraine und werden hier mit
offenen armen empfangen wie marion
geiger berichtet
von oksana kölner endlich ihre liebsten
umarmen ihre schwester nicht neffen und
weitere verwandte sind zu ihr und ihrem
mann geflüchtet mit dem autor aus dem
krieg über 3000 kilometer ins
rheinhessische wallertheim
ich bin so froh dass alle sind schon da
in sicherheit
täglich kommen tausende flüchtender
ukrainerinnen in deutschland an zwischen
bund ländern und kommunen laufen
gespräche wie die menschen verteilt
werden unterkünfte sind ausreichend da
sagt der städte und gemeindebund fordert
aber geld wir erwarten natürlich von
bund und ländern dass die kosten von
denen getragen werden die vertriebenen
selbst haben anspruch nach dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz
und die kosten können die kommunen die
schultern sondern das müssen bund und
länder finanzieren in wallertheim sind
alle privat untergebracht die kinder
sollen hier zur schule gehen wobei es
schwer ist an die zukunft zu denken ohne
zu wissen was aus der familie in der
ukraine wird
meine eltern sind in der ukraine
geblieben meine schwester und ich sind
allein hier das ist sehr schwer
sie halten kontakt und machen sich mut
hoffen darauf sich bald wieder zu sehen
in ihrem neuen leben voller ungewissheit
mit geldspenden können sie den menschen
in der ukraine helfen auch denen die auf
der flucht sind zum beispiel beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine alle
infos auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de
oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
viele ukraine leben in ständiger angst
die menschen hier fühlen eine gewisse
ohnmacht fragen sich was sie konkret tun
können um zu helfen und um die lage zu
entschärfen irgendwie verbunden damit
sind zukunftsängste wird der krieg auch
uns irgendwann unmittelbar betreffen wie
dieser krieg auch die psyche belastet
damit hat sich das thomson beschäftigt
ein meer aus menschen an der alster in
hamburg zehntausende gingen heute mittag
auf die straße um gegen den krieg in
ukraine zu demonstrieren auf den
transparenten spiegelt sich nicht nur
die abscheu vor dem russischen angriff
sondern auch angst vor einer weiteren
eskalation und einer ungewissen zukunft
unsere generation hat so krieg so nahe
ich noch nie erlebt zumindest keinen
angriffskrieg und deswegen haben wir
schon zukunftsangst nur das kann sich ja
schnell ändern die sehr komfortable
situation wo er auch russische
demonstranten wie einer aus sankt
petersburg plagen sorgen um die zukunft
mit der heutigen regierung sehen wir
ehrlich gesagt keine zukunft das haben
die letzten tage gezeigt aber eigentlich
auch die letzten jahre und jahrzehnte wo
das regime
zunehmend repressiver geworden ist erst
klimakrise dann corona und jetzt auch
noch der krieg immer mehr menschen so
psychologen kämpfen mit massiven ängsten
es sind auch nicht nur ängste das sind
teilweise natürlich auch
konzentrationsstörungen oder
schlafstörungen das gefühl die kontrolle
ein stück weit zu verlieren über das
leben der experte mahnt in dieser
situation umsichtig mit sich unter
umwelt zu sein
manchmal ist auch gut eine gewisse
informations pause zu machen also nicht
24 stunden am tag sich informationen zu
holen so alge faktum allgemeine faktoren
die die resilienz steigern das kann
sport sein bewegung das kann auch mal
irgendwie entspannung sein ist wichtig
soziale unterstützung also gespräche mit
freunden suchen es wichtig und auch
demonstrationen wie heute in hamburg
seien hilfreich für das gefühl nicht
allein zu sein und um nicht in
verzweiflung zu fall
zur situation in der ukraine sendet das
zdf ein spezial gleich im anschluss an
diese nachrichten jederzeit aktuell
informieren können sie sich mit der zdf
heute app der krieg macht nicht nur öl
und gas teurer auch der preis für weizen
erreicht historische höchstwerte die
ukraine gilt als kornkammer europas
beide kriegsparteien zusammen die
ukraine und russland liefern rund ein
drittel des weltweit gehandelten weizens
vor allem nach nordafrika und in den
nahen osten
in vielen ländern droht jetzt eine
ernährungskrise an seinem stern hat
details
der krieg des kreml herrschers sendet
schockwellen in die weltwirtschaft seit
putins blutigen überfall steigen etwa
die weltmarktpreise für weizen
dramatisch an von 290 auf jetzt 396 euro
pro tonne ein plus von fast 37 prozent
und je länger dieser konflikt andauert
desto teurer werden lebensmittel werden
desto schwieriger wird das lebensmittel
zu bekommen und auch zu verteilen noch
größere hungersnöte drohen warnen die
vereinten nationen etwa im jemen auch
andere länder in der arabischen welt
brauchen weizen aus russland und der
ukraine
und sie brauchen die lieferungen der
hilfsorganisationen für uns wird die
arbeit natürlich viel schwieriger wenn
wir mit dem vorhandenen geld weniger
lebensmittel kaufen können aber auch zb
mit einem extrem hohen ölpreis steigen
unsere transportkosten so dass wir
weniger menschen erreichen können
verbraucher in deutschland müssen wohl
bald mehr bezahlen die branche sorgt
sich um kleine unternehmen
es ist eben so dass die größeren
betriebe oft langfristige kontrakte
haben wir kaufen also ihren weizen von
ihrer mühle ein jahr im voraus mit der
energie ist das genauso gerade kleinere
betriebe können diese kontakte aber
nicht abschliessen den kombi nicht
angeboten
immer mehr rohstoffe immer teurer das
sind die aussichten wir hatten bereits
vor der ukraine krise damit gerechnet
dass wir eine inflation sehen würden von
vier bis viereinhalb prozent in diesem
jahr wenn jetzt gas erdöl und damit
benzin strom weiter ansteigen dann wird
natürlich diese inflation auch noch
weiter zunehmen weiter zunehmen werden
vor allem hunger leid und not in vielen
teilen der welt wegen des krieges des
kreml herrschers
putins angriff auf die ukraine hat
russland international weitgehend
isoliert eine mächtige ausnahme ist
china das weigert sich bislang den
überfall zu verurteilen beim nationalen
volkskongress hat heute die
kommunistische partei den krieg nicht
mal erwähnt allerdings trifft er auf
chinas wirtschaft und verschärft die
durch die pandemie ohnehin schon großen
unsicherheiten aus peking christiane
hoffnungen von dong von in südchina
gehen diese lautsprecher in die welt
doch cupid hat ingenieurs fabrik spuren
hinterlassen durch produktionsstopps und
stark gestiegene frachtkosten so schnell
wird es nicht besser wir haben uns
darauf eingestellt dass wir das ganze
jahr noch durchhalten müssen
von 700 mitarbeitern beschäftigt er nur
noch die hälfte und wie ihm geht es
vielen mit der standler chinas
wirtschaft leidet die aussichten
unsicher auch durch den ukraine krieg
beim nationalen volkskongress stimmte
die regierung die delegierten deshalb
auf ein schwieriges jahr ein
prognostiziert mit 5,5 prozent das
niedrigste wachstum seit 30 jahren
der druck auf die wirtschaft ist relativ
groß die regierung nutzt dafür drei
worte geschrumpfte nachfrage gestörte
lieferketten und abgeschwächte
erwartungen
mehr als im vergangenen jahr investiert
das autokratische regime ins militär
wendet sich gleichzeitig gegen
ausländische einmischung in taiwan sowie
gegen die nato und die usa
china wird weiterhin seine unabhängige
außenpolitik des friedens verfolgen für
eine neue form der internationalen
beziehungen arbeiten und sich bemühen
eine weltgemeinschaft für eine
gemeinsame zukunft zu bauen
den ukraine krieg hat der regierungschef
nicht erwähnt doch in chains fabrik
spüren sie schon die folgen eine
großbestellung aus der ukraine wurde
gerade studiert sie macht ein zehntel
seiner produktion aus china
hat sich in dem krieg bislang auf keine
seite geschlagen sieht russland als
strategischen partner und voller in
peking könnte china als vermittler
helfen
ich glaube zumindest dass die
chinesische regierung sich in der rolle
des vermittlers sieht und vor allem auch
den internationalen druck spürt stärker
als vermittler aufzutreten
der chinesische außenminister hat heute
noch mal sehr deutlich gesagt dass
dieser konflikt nur über gespräche und
verhandlungen zu lösen sei die
chinesische regierung glaubt einfach
dass dieser krieg viel zu lange schon in
der ukraine dauert dass es zu viele
zivile tote gibt das eben die
weltwirtschaft darunter leidet und damit
auch die chinesische und dass dieser
krieg eben das westliche bündnis
militärbündnis wieder zusammengeschweißt
hat alles dinge die china nicht will
deswegen glaube ich schon dass die
chinesische regierung im hintergrund
versucht die russische regierung davon
zu überzeugen doch mehr zu verhandeln
und mehr eine diplomatische lösung zu
suchen ob putin wirklich auf china hört
das kann ich nicht sagen aber wenn es
jemand gibt auf den putin hört dann ist
es wahrscheinlich nur shipping der
chinesische präsident die einschätzung
unseres china korrespondenten vielen
dank und freude
zur corona lage da waren
gesundheitsminister lauterbach vor einer
infektionswelle im sommer den funke
zeitungen sagte er selbst bei gutem
wetter könne es zu steigenden zahlen
kommen wenn es gar keine einschränkungen
mehr gebe aktuell registriert das rk ii
192 1210 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden das sind 16
1377 mehr als vor einer woche außerdem
kamen innerhalb eines tages
255 todesfälle hinzu die sieben tage
incidents steigt auf rund
in österreich liegt die inzidenz fast
doppelt so hoch wie in deutschland
dennoch sind dort heute nahezu alle
corona beschränkungen gefallen seit
mitternacht dürfen etwa diskotheken
wieder öffnen nach zwei jahren corona
pause war der andrang riesig allein die
hauptstadt wien geht nicht alle öffnungs
schritte mit und hält unter anderem an
der zweig regel in der gastronomie fest
und jetzt der sport christian die
paralympics ging für die deutschen ganz
gut los es macht wirklich lust auf mehr
vier medaillen gleich am ersten tag ein
verheißungsvoller auftakt für das
deutsche team in peking dreimal silber
und einmal bronze im ski alpin und
biathlon einfach nur sensationell
schwärmt teamchef friedhelm julius
beucher
erste deutsche fahnenträgerin einen tag
später schon die silbermedaille
anna-lena forster beginnt die
paralympics äußerst erfolgreich in der
monarchie abfahrt ein nahezu
fehlerfreies rennen hinter der japanerin
naoko gewinnt sie ihre sechste medaille
bei paralympischen spielen
silber auch für biathleten marco meyer
über sechs kilometer kämpft sich der
22-jährige aus kirchzarten in der
stehenden klasse sein erstes
internationales edelmetall
in katzmaier gelingt aber die größte
überraschung in der klasse der
sehbehinderten mit 15 jahren die
zweitjüngste teilnehmer in den peking
und mit silber im citroen sie sich zur
jüngsten deutschen medaillengewinnerin
bei winterspielen überhaupt den guten
deutschen auftakt komplettiert leonie
walter im selben rennen mit bronze
zwei deutsche podestplätze beim biathlon
weltcup im finnischen kontiolahti in den
sprintwettbewerben platz drei für
johannes kühn beim sieg des franzosen
jean marie herausragend lief es für
einzel olympiasiegerin denise herrmann
der erste dank galt den ski sie liefen
einfach prächtig und mit ihnen die minis
hermann zu musik richtig gutes material
und und fließend das ließ sie einfach
ablaufen die bedingungen waren und ja
schießen hat dann auch wirklich gut
geklappt die bedingungen am schießstand
in kontiolahti schon naturgemäß
kompliziert dennoch diniz hermann
liegend fehlerfrei dazu auf der strecke
in topform da konnte sie sich sogar
einen fehler stehend erlauben am ende
fünf sekunden der vorsprung im ziel auf
die norweger lag auf platz drei geht als
ziel an ihr zorn aus schweden
ja und freude auch bei den deutschen
skispringern markus eisenbichler kam am
holmenkollen in oslo von der großschanze
gut zurecht und wurde zweiter hinter
olympiasieger marius ludwig aus norwegen
in der fußball bundesliga erneut
gedenken und viele zeichen gegen den
krieg in der ukraine
sportlich kassiert bayern münchen einen
dämpfer eins zu eins im eigenen stadion
gegen leverkusen die bayer-elf
profitiert dabei vom ersten eigentor von
thomas müller in einem pflichtspiel
leipzig rettet 1 1 2 1 gegen freiburg
wolfsburg union berlin 1 0 debakel für
hertha bsc 1 zu 4 gegen frankfurt bochum
greuther fürth zwei zu eins im
abendspiel stuttgart gladbach gestern
bielefeld augsburg 0 2 1 in der oberen
tabellenhälfte bisher keine veränderung
in der reihenfolge alle spitzenteams die
gespielt haben im gleichschritt mit
einem punktgewinn bis auf union berlin
durch die niederlage in der unteren
hälfte holen frankfurt bochum und
wolfsburg auf augsburg und bielefeld
tauschen im abstiegskampf härte auf dem
relegationsplatz sowie die
schlusslichter stuttgart und greuther
fürth und mehr dazu wie gewohnt 23 uhr
10 heute im aktuellen sportstudio
dankeschön christiane draußen bleibt es
trocken und sonnig mehr zum wetter hat
gleich aus dem verlies marietta slomka
begrüßt sie um 22 uhr 40 im heute
journal
wir danken für ihr interesse wünschen
ihnen alles gute und sind morgen wieder
da auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
15 beamte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter das nächste hoch macht sich breit
und blockiert wieder mal den weg der
tiefs und so haben erst einmal
regenwolken keine chance dafür kommt
relativ kühle teils kalte luft aus dem
osten
und so sind die nächte vor allem in den
nächsten tagen immer noch eisig kalt wir
schauen in die kommende nacht und da
gibt es im osten viele wolken sonst klar
dass nach westen und südwesten hin auf
teils bildet sich nebel und die
temperaturen gehen an den alpen bis auf
minus zehn grad zurück häufig werte im
frostbereich einzig an der nordsee was
bei plus 1 grad morgen tagesverlauf dann
im osten einige worten die herein
driften aber insgesamt trocken im westen
mehr sonnenschein und vor allem im
südwesten mit höchsten temperaturen von
bis zu 1 grad nach osten hin und teils 6
8 grad in den westlichen landesteilen
wir schauen auf die aussichten oder gibt
es viel sonnenschein vor allem im osten
dann am montag bei temperaturen von zwei
bis neun grad und danach steigen die
temperaturen ganz langsam an die nächte
bleiben frostig ein schulamt